get out
loud
Miranda Lambert is extending her talents
to more than just country music dropping
a new cookbook called y'all eat yet
filled with mouth-watering recipes from
friends and family and the stories
behind them I learned a lot around the
kitchen with these ladies the bitching
pigeon for so many reasons so I just
want this book to be like a centerpiece
for people to
like a reminder for them to you know
surround themselves with great people
and how important a tribe is for you you
know it's really important to have
surround yourself with people who
celebrate the good times and who hold
you up with the bad times that's what
this whole book's about
[Music]
I feel like for me at all sorts of music
you know I've really faced everything
in my life around around food and music
so it makes sense that they go hand in
hand you know a lot of the songs early
on that I had written when I hadn't
really lived a lot of laughs myself yet
because I was 17 when I started writing
a lot of the information I gathered
around the dinner table or hanging out
with with these ladies in this cookbook
were my grandmother's best friends were
just little bits of life that I was
gathering and some of my first songs
were written about some of the stories
that they were going through you know I
had lived it myself yet but I really
absorbed that and the country singer
says nothing goes with a delicious meal
quite like a celebration our group is
all about celebrating we'll find any
excuse to celebrate and to throw a party
um the potini bar actually started at um
at my mom's in her Cantina it was a big
party and it was a brilliant idea it's
mashed potatoes in a in a martini glass
and then you have all the toppings in
the world and it's like super fun
interactive inexpensive and it's you
know it's just it's easy and it's really
cute
[Music]